there's a very interesting report and
truth out about the reality that just a
ton of Americans are heading to Mexico
for medical treatment because of the
high quality and relatively low-cost
care that they can just pay
out-of-pocket for their instead of
getting care in the United States so
this is a different sort of Caravan than
the one that we've been hearing about on
Fox News and from Donald Trump this is a
caravan you're not going to hear that
much about but I've actually been
following this for a very long time
medical tourism is a thing it's a sort
of arbitrage arbitrage when in general
what arbitrage means is you take
advantage of the different costs of the
same thing in different places so this
could be buying a product in one place
and then bringing it elsewhere and
selling it that might be one type of
arbitrage that you can do or if you can
borrow money from someone at 2% and then
invest it at two and a half percent
guaranteed risk-free you can leverage
that and gain 0.5 percent interest that
would be another form of arbitrage and
here we're talking about healthcare
services which means that even when you
account for travel costs Americans can
still save a lot of money by getting
health services in other countries
compared to in the United States this
includes in Asia in some cases this
includes in Europe in some cases in some
cases it's Mexico and that's the one
we're talking about today and of course
it depends on which country what type of
healthcare services you're looking for
when it comes to Mexico
it is a lot of dentistry and quite a bit
of optometry as well there are 6,000
Americans each day that are crossing the
Yuma Arizona
border crossing to go to the Mexican
town of Los Algodones which translates
literally as Cotton's to get care mostly
dental work and no cellular onus has
more dentists per capita than anywhere
in the world I actually took a
screenshot of Google Maps above the town
this is just that one zoom level if I
had zoomed in I might have been able to
find even more dental offices but I've
served
for people who are watching right now in
like a three block by two block radius
roughly there are at least six dentistry
clinics and a dental school just in this
small area this is a tiny town of 5,000
people you might also notice on this map
that there are a lot of optometrists and
pharmacies as well and a lot of what's
going on here is just demand
I mean dental care is a huge problem in
the United States there are 74 million
people in the United States who don't
have dental insurance many are not by
choice so like I've mentioned before on
the show I stopped I chose to stop
having dental insurance when I was 26
and was removed or lost coverage under
my parents plan and I made that choice
because I figured out okay based on the
fact that most most dental insurance
costs between three and five hundred
dollars per year and often has a yearly
maximum coverage of a thousand or
fifteen hundred dollars aside from your
two regular cleanings a year based on me
getting two cleanings and having like
one cavity filled every year and a half
or two years or so I figured I'll just
save the money on the insurance and pay
out-of-pocket but that's a choice on
making right it's not out of necessity
and a lot of people don't have dental
insurance for other reasons and when you
look at the cost over the counter of a
lot of procedures in the United States
you might have a two hundred two
thousand dollar rather crown you might
have a five thousand dollar dental
implant elderly folks sometimes will
have to have a number of crowns done at
once or a number of implants done at
once and it is just way cheaper and
still very good care to go to Mexico to
do this if you look at some of the
storefronts in the Mexican town across
from Yuma Arizona of Los Algodones you
see that they're totally set up for
Americans right here is a storefront
from Google Maps Street View at the
molar dental clinic which says that they
provide the face of a great smile they
offer implants crowns root canals ten
and partials it's all in English right
so this is set up for Americans known to
have terrible dental care so why does
this matter right like why in the
context of the so called border crisis
does this matter
Americans legally going to Mexico for
health care doesn't change that it's
illegal to come to the United States
illegally but consider the scale for a
second okay we are told by US Customs
and Border Protection that 20,000 to
60,000 people per month are crossing
from Mexico to the United States in this
one town in Mexico almost five times as
many health care tourists are going into
Mexico to get work done there are more
people leaving the american health care
system to get care in mexico just in
this one town than the number that's
coming to the u.s. from Mexico and
Central America fleeing violence and
we're supposed to pretend that the
crisis is people coming here rather than
the abject failures of our health care
system and one of the richest countries
in the United States and of course the
irony is or maybe better said the double
standard is that the Trump
administration is lobbying for a wall to
protect Americans from mostly refugees
and people looking for work while we
want to be able to go there to
circumvent the terrible health care
system of the United States whenever we
want the real crisis here Pat is the
health care system and that is what I
think is completely missing from the
conversation yes strictly speaking what
difference does it make in terms of what
our immigration policy should be that
the health care system is so messed up
that people are crossing to Mexico to
get dental work fine point taken but the
scope of what's going on is completely
disproportionate to the crisis that we
were told exists yeah building a
physical wall will not only keep people
from coming into the country yeah I
guess in theory you would keep people
from going out of the country too it
goes both ways they would be kind of
like the Berlin Wall in that sense and
yeah we shouldn't be surprised by this
immigration to Mexico is below Net Zero
meaning more people are going out than
coming in this so-called immigration
crisis isn't a crisis at all and this is
a very interesting story that you're
bringing up here it's important to
mention that this healthcare tourism's
not for all conditions so for example if
you consider like plastic surgery which
is mostly elective procedures but not
all there are lots of examples of people
finding significantly cheaper plastic
surgery in other countries but that can
be a much more complex thing if you want
to be able to get full care when it
comes to plastic surgery it's often
beneficial to stay for aftercare in the
case of complications where the doctor
that did the procedure can see that
through to the very end there are many
situations of people ending up with
complications and then going to an
American doctor for a cosmetic procedure
they had elsewhere and the American
doctor of course doesn't know the
details of the case and how the
operation was initially done so I'm not
someone saying travel to wherever it's
cheapest and just get care what I am
saying is that there are places that are
very good and much more affordable for
particular procedures Mexico and in
particular this region of Mexico is very
good and affordable when it comes to
dental work and a lot of those
procedures are ones that inherently come
with fewer complications not medical
advice but just a report of what it is
that is taking place let me know what
you think I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show we will go to the phones we've got
a great interview for you we will take
some audience questions and the bonus
show this week is a good one it's all
around a good program for you today
today's program brought to you in part
by Blink accom slash Pakman blinkie's is
a great service that I use all the time
what they do is they take thousands of
the most popular nonfiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink as'
I recently checked out soccer na mcc's
by Simon Cooper we do have after all the
World Cup going on recently we also have
been
talking about BS jobs and there is a
great new book of BS jobs by David
Graeber which I listened to on blinka
they're constantly adding new books to
the platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
is calm slash Pakman if you're watching
on YouTube I'm putting a link in the
video description and after the free
trial if you like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
that's be Li NK is t.com /pa k mas